Many of the people in the top 100
are barely breaking even,
sometimes in the red.
If you're not playing at
Grand Slams consistently
and doing well...
you are struggling.
When I grew up, I always
watched tennis.
So watching Williams sisters
and everything
my sister and I, we grew up
playing together
and so I always wanted to be
like Venus and Serena.
So I come from Poland, which is
not a huge tennis culture.
I would say my mom
used to play tennis
and that's how I started
when I wanted to...
become one of the best players
in the world.
I was the first number one junior
in 37 years, female.
And kind of all my dreams
started coming true.
The perception versus the reality
like tennis does look very glam
and it looks so polished.
The highest paid this,
and these big purses
and these big prize money tournaments...
you really don't see the struggle.
That was something that...
I didn't really understand
until I got to that level.
And then once I got to
the top 100...
then my ranking fell to 400.
And then that was the time when
I had to go back
to playing like the really
low level events.
And I didn't know how I was going
to pay my bills.
I told my coach like there were times like...
“Hey, I can’t pay you.”
or  “I can’t pay for training
this week.”
or “Can you pay for your flight?”
And then, “Yo, I got you.”
When we get to the slam and like
when we get to the bigger tournaments.
So the structure of tennis
is pretty unique in the
sports landscape.
There's a men's tour: the ATP.
There's a women's tour: the WTA.
There's four Grand Slams,
which are each
really independently owned
and operated.
There's the International Tennis Federation
which is like the global governing body
that governs things like the Olympics
and some of the more global
aspects of tennis.
And you have this really disjointed structure...
When you add it all up, has left
not only the players behind
and made it something
that is not anywhere close
to where it should be in relation
to other sports.
You’d think the total revenue of tennis
could be better.
The percentage that the players
are getting, I think that...
that's also some issue.
The tournaments are sharing
about 18% of the revenue
with the players.
In many of those other sports,
hockey, American football, soccer...
you see a revenue share that is
much closer to 50%.
As a player, sometimes it is frustrating because
you know that you're the talent
and you know that you're bringing
this certain level of entertainment
to all of these different places
around the world...
and not being compensated for it.
Tennis is a sport where
there are no teams.
And so it...
if anything, that revenue share
should be higher in tennis...
given the fact that people
are coming to see
Player A play against
Player B.
Carlos Alcaraz made the most money
on either the men’s tour
or the women's tour last year,
about $10 Million.
Who is, by the way,
a generational talent...
who won an incredible amount
of matches last year.
And let’s asterisk that for a second
because that's gross.
That's before he pays his own travel,
his coaches...
his physios, all the expenses
that tennis players bear alone.
That no athlete in a team sport
or other sports, like F1,
have to bear.
And if you look at $10 million...
how that translates in basketball,
that's roughly
the 150th highest paid player
in the NBA.
And then you look at football,
American football
that’s 202nd highest salary.
In baseball, it’s a similar story
where it's in the hundreds...
out of a 6-700 player community
at the major league level.
That graphic is like tattooed in my head
because it's astonishing to me.
There are a lot more players
that are struggling than
the ones that aren't.
A good friend of mine, Dustin Brown,
a very, very good player.
He literally was living out of his car.
He was stringing rackets
for the players at the tournament
to make money.
And sometimes the amount that
he was making to string rackets
was more than he made in his prize money.
And he beat Nadal at Wimbledon.
Like, played one of the most epic matches.
“Game set and that’s Brown.”
And the pressure always gets
spun around and put onto them.
Well, if you just won more, you'd be fine.
So what's your problem?
Well, if you weren't in the two hundreds
or three hundreds, well, then
you'd have nothing to complain about.
As opposed to...
Hey, wait a second.
In all these other global sports...
if I'm in the two hundreds,
three hundreds...
I'm actually well entrenched
as a professional athlete.
Why isn't that the case in tennis?
It's one of the only sports where
we're not salary base players.
Your pay is based on your performance.
The way those other sports
are structured
the players are employees.
And so when you're an employee,
you have a minimum salary...
and part of the problem with tennis
is that the players, despite...
working 11 and a half months a year...
traveling the globe
are treated as independent contractors.
I guess people who don't
have endorsements...
they only make their money
from tournaments.
And I don't think that
that should be a thing.
I think we should make like
salary for the year.
I'm fortunate to have, you know...
a couple of great sponsors.
I’m wearing a watch while I play.
Actually, this watch while I play.
Also, I'm playing with a Yonex racket,
a Yonex outfit
and having a patch on my sleeve
for Easy Post.
I'm sponsored by ASICS
at the moment.
They send you a package of clothes
to wear at different tournaments.
That's based on your ranking and also
your profile as a player.
And if you're 200 in the world, maybe...
you know, maybe there's a local company
from your country
that wants to help you, wants to support you.
But if you're outside of top 50...
you will have a clothing, the other
you will have a racket deal.
But it would be touch to have a real source
of income outside of a tennis court.
And in my particular situation,
I don't have any sponsors.
So, like all of my expenses come out
of my prize money.
Traveling with a couple of people around the world.
You know, you fly always last minute
and you sleep in the hotels
you eat in restaurants.
Those expenses are really, really significant.
Maybe a coach a year is around
$75,000 without expenses.
So for hotel, flights
all that, it could add up.
There's so much emphasis on the Grand Slams
because these four times a year,
only four...
are where you get basically the biggest payout.
When you're at the lower rankings
or you're trying to break through.
Like you kind of have to go everywhere
because you need to get points,
you need to get money.
Points are literally everything.
I mean, that's how our rankings
are determined.
And every tournament has
a certain point value...
and every round has a certain point value.
So at the Grand Slams is where you can
make the most points.
And the lower level tournaments like the 250s
or even like challenger...
the lower you drop down,
the less point
opportunities that you have to make.
So it's just back and forth, back and forth,
back and forth.
Often times the expenses
outweigh the pay.
The sport hasn't kept pace
with other sports.
The players and what they generate
from an income standpoint...
hasn't kept pace.
The protections are non-existent.
There's no safety net.
There's no minimum.
Because what happens if you get hurt?
What happens if you want to
take a break?
have a child?
There's no mechanism for that...
other than putting 100% of that burden
on the player.
Fortunately, my parents were able
to help me a lot in my career
and I'm really thankful to them.
If you don't have support,
it's really challenging.
The risk...
is that we can...
miss out on really unique
and amazing talents and people
who are very, very good...
because they can't afford to play.
Players like Ons Jabeur...
she didn't have those opportunities
growing up in Tunisia.
Frances Tiafoe.
I mean, those are players who made it...
despite those challenges,
made it.
What about all the other players that didn't?
I'm trying to identify and really get clear on like...
how can I make the biggest difference?
I feel like if I don't do that or if I don't try, like...
I'm wasting...
all the things that I've been through
and the lessons that I learn.
Like I want to pass that on
to as many people as I can.
And if I can shape a next
generational talent...
I will love that.